the left believes that your children are
theirs to control and parents are
fighting back joe biden's approval
ratings continue to tank and the white
house continues to flail over ukraine
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first remember using the
internet without expressvpn it's like
leaving your laptop open on a coffee
shop table while you run to the restroom
it's probably okay most of the time and
then you come out one day and there's
some weird guy who's just browsing
through your emails why would you do
that you wouldn't and so why would you
leave all of your internet activity out
there for anyone else to take a look at
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network cafes hotels airports any hacker
on the same network can gain access to
your personal data it doesn't take a lot
of technical knowledge to hack somebody
some cheap hardware and half a brain
basically your data is valuable hackers
can make up to a thousand dollars per
person selling personal information on
the dark web so why is expressvpn well
first of all it creates an encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet hackers cannot steal your
sensitive data and it's super secure it
would take a hacker with a supercomputer
over a billion years to get past that
expressive vpn encryption my favorite
thing it's really easy to use you hit
one button and you download it and then
you hit another button and you're ready
to go it works on all your devices phone
laptops tablet and more so you can stay
secure on the go secure your online data
today visit
expressvpn.com that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
you get an extra three months for free
expressivevpn.com
ben well joe biden's numbers are just
terrible they are in the toilet one year
in this president has failed he has
completely and comprehensively failed
the good news is that he is sending out
hallmark valentine's day cards on his
twitter he hopes that this will help
recast him in a new light for the
american public so here is the president
of the united states today on twitter
here's what he said and i think we need
a little bit of um romantic music
for this here we go
one year ago
he started to write an american story of
hope now fear
of unity not division
of light not darkness
an american story of decency and dignity
of love
and healing
of greatness and of goodness
may this be the story
that continues to guide us
for nancy james
oh romantic
stuff from the president of the united
states actually one year ago you had a
54 to 56 approval rating and now you are
in the low 30s according to a
multiplicity of polls there's a poll out
today
that is the most important poll which is
how many people actually wish to see joe
biden run for re-election in 2024.
the answer 28 of americans are like i
would love to see that guy run for
re-election 28 of americans that is joe
biden and his immediate family and
hunter biden's illegitimate child those
are the people who want joe biden to run
for reelection and i don't even know if
hunter biden's legitimate child feels
that way
right now according to the associated
press more americans disapprove than
approve of how biden is handling his job
as president 56 to 43
as of now just 28 of americans say they
want joe biden to run for re-election in
2024 including only 48 percent of
democrats less than half of democrats
want the incumbent's democratic
president who just won a supposed
landslide victory over donald trump to
run for reelection you know how bad that
is those numbers are abysmal
in july 59 of americans said they
approved of biden's job performance that
is a 16 point drop
his approval rating dipped to 50 percent
by late september because of afghanistan
and then it just kept on dropping
i mean the numbers look like
like they had to get into dr strangelove
riding the bomb into the ground that's
that's what the trajectory of these
numbers look like his approval rating
among democrats went from 97 percent at
the beginning of his tenure to 76 today
okay he has lost 21 among democrats
which is insane he went from 61 among
independents to 43 percent among
independents
he went from 23 among republicans to 9
among republicans
medias are terrible terrible numbers
and as for joe biden's contention in his
hallmark valentine's day card that he's
bringing unity
only 16 of americans think biden's
president's presidency has made the
country more united 43 think it's more
divided well ironically he has united
the country against him everybody thinks
that he sucks at this
when 84 of americans
agree that joe biden's president has not
made the country more united that's a
pretty solid level
of agreement actually
only 28 of americans say they have a
great deal of confidence in biden to
effectively manage the white house that
is down from 44 who said that one year
ago
some 33 said that they have some
confidence
38 said no no confidence at all and his
numbers within demographics key
demographic groups just terrible
according to a brand new nbc poll
they say 44 is his approval rating among
registered voters that sounds high to me
but
okay here is the problem here are his
numbers among various demographic groups
okay he is at 36 with independence
he's at 64 with black voters to be down
to 64 approval rating among black voters
is insane that is down 19
from april
among young voters 18 to 34 right this
is the demographic that is going to
change the future they're all going to
love joe biden
18 to 34 voters
only 40 of them say they like joe biden
four zero percent
among hispanics the number is 48 so a
minority of hispanics like joe biden
even among women which is the the best
demographic group for for joe biden
or one of the best he's only at 51
these numbers are viciously brutal
they're just terrible
now i assume that what joe biden is
doing now
he's trying to show up to black support
he's trying to shore up the female
support and the young support it ain't
working
it just isn't
and right now they are cruising for a a
record bruising come november
i think there's every opportunity for
the republicans to pick up about 40
seats in the house leaving them with a
252-seat majority in the house of
representatives which would be a
historically large majority for the
republicans in the house of
representatives one you know one
election after joe biden swept through
and took with him congress as well as
the senate
and this is what karl rove is saying in
the wall street journal today
he says the more joe biden pushed for
transformational change while holding a
razor thin house margin in a 50-50
senate the more negative public opinion
grew the president's job approval fell
from 56 percent approved to 36
disapproved at the start of his
presidency to 41 to prove 53 disapprove
now in the real clear politics average
this happened in part because he hasn't
focused on problems that ordinary
americans face instead he wanted a
smorgasbord of new welfare benefits and
build back better few of which would
help voters worried that prices were
growing at the grocery store and gas
pump much faster than their paychecks
and here's the thing biden keeps
doubling down so in that horrifying
press conference the other day i think
the worst press conference i've ever
seen in that press conference where a
barely sentient
elderly gentleman babbled nonsensically
while handing ukraine to the russians in
the middle of that he was asked about
re-jiggering his presidency
what can you do in terms of comms
and his answer was that he was going to
go talk with presidential historians
this was his problem in the first place
apparently he had a meeting early on in
his administration with a guy named john
meacham john meacham
is this presidential historian the
self-appointed conscience of the of the
historian community which he has not but
he hasn't pointed himself thus and he's
the guy who told joe biden that he could
be fdr or lbj
and joe biden's solution is to go back
to john meacham by the way meacham was
supposedly one of the authors on that
terrible speech that biden just gave
down in georgia that kind of put the
capstone on his crappy presidency so far
where he called all of his opponents
vicious racists and then tried to
lecture reporters on how they didn't
understand english for quoting him
so joe biden is in very very very
serious trouble
and here's the thing i think that
serious political trouble is something
that that attends many presidents from
time to time
the problem for joe biden is it has now
become systemic this is a systemic
problem within the democratic party
because the entire democratic party
agenda is the problem it is not how joe
biden presents to the world
joe biden presents kind of the same way
he always has as a doofus
he doesn't present particularly as a
nefarious force in america
he doesn't present to somebody who's
innately vicious and cruel and mean
i think he has that edge but a lot of
people don't
the problem for joe biden is that his
agenda is just unpopular and democrats
have bought into the agenda and what's
worse
they've made a cardinal error here and
that is they've created a brand new
interest group and that brand new
interest group is parents
this is the thing the republicans for
the first time
since probably about 2004 are grasping
that cultural issues matter to the
american people trump got this on sort
of an innate level he knew where the
energy was he didn't talk about tax cuts
and tariffs instead he talked about the
the racial essentialism being pushed by
the democrats he talked about crime he
talked about
all of these sort of social issues that
affected americans on a day-to-day level
anyone because of that well republicans
are picked up on this and democrats are
just steering directly into the oh i
would say they were steering into the
skid except they shouldn't right they're
actually steering away from the skid and
so now they're in a tailspin
we'll get to more of this in just one
moment first
have you ever gone exclusive with
somebody i remember when i first went
exclusive with my wife which was pretty
quickly you have the butterfly feeling
in your stomach well i'll tell you that
feeling can only be recapitulated when
you start buying meat exclusively with
good ranchers the 100 american meat
company once we laid eyes on the steaks
from good ranchers it was hunger at
first sight they sell beef that is 100
born raised harvested right here in the
united states that is a big deal
considering 85 percent of the grass-fed
beef sold in stores and online is
imported from overseas with good
ranchers you help support local american
farms and ranches while getting
steakhouse quality cuts delivered
straight to your door they win on
quality price and mission that is why we
are so excited to partner with them they
take good care of us they'll take great
care of you bunch of people in the
office have been eating nothing but good
ranchers and let me tell you these are
the happiest people in the office head
on over to goodranchers.com
get their biggest offer ever 30 bucks
off your first order plus free express
shipping use code bennett checkout or go
to
goodranchers.com get 30 bucks off your
box of delicious american meat order
today get american meat delivered with
good ranchers okay so
one of the cardinal rules of american
politics do not create new interest
groups that are aligned against you
particularly if they constitute a huge
swath of the american people
parents have never really been an
interest group in american politics in
2004 republicans came kind of close over
the issues of same-sex marriage and
national security right there are the
security mobs but
those issues
realistically speaking we're we're not
i think as big as the democrats have now
made the parenting issue because
democrats have basically declared their
allegiance to a progressive left that
believes that your children do not
belong to you and so whenever democrats
now say that they are acting on behalf
of the children it sounds a lot like
you're acting on behalf of my children
against me
and my answer to that is no you don't
know my kids you don't care about my
kids i don't think nancy pelosi gives a
damn about my children i know that that
is pretty much all i think about 24
hours a day i'm the one up in the middle
of the night trying to figure out how to
make their lives better not nancy pelosi
but when democrats say they're trying to
make your kids life better what they
really mean is they're trying to service
particular constituencies and they're
going to try to mold children in order
to do so so here's nancy pelosi talking
up her agenda with regard to the kids
yesterday
my whole mission in congress is about
the children for the children
as you've heard me say
you're in the arena you have to be
prepared to take a punch
you have to be prepared to throw a punch
for the children
for the children you have to prep to
outfit the children so i eat gelato out
of a twenty thousand dollar fridge while
masking children
and teaching them that they can be
members of the opposite sex
nothing says for the children quite like
the democratic agenda which is kill
babies before they're born after they're
born tell them that they can members of
the opposite sex and teach them that
racial essentialism is a key factor in
american life
nothing says for the children quite like
that
now the reality is that for progressive
left movements the idea of perfecting
humanity in pursuit of utopia has always
been a part of the scheme if you go all
the way back to rousseau the idea of
educating children in a particular
fashion so as to achieve some sort of
communal end this has been a large part
of every left-wing movement since the
inception of left-wing movements and
philosophically speaking it goes all the
way back to plato i mean if you actually
read the republic plato talks about
taking kids away from their parents and
then indoctrinating them in particular
values that they will be better citizens
of the police so anybody who has utopian
visions
has to use children as malleable weapons
in that fight
but in order to do that in a traditional
country that has institutions like
parenting in church
and local communities in order to do
that you have to separate kids from
their parents
and this is what you're seeing in the
battle over education
see for a long time the educational
battle between republicans and democrats
was just how much money should we spend
on education
and there are debates over school choice
and the crappiness of our public schools
and all of that but then the left has
they've been making increasingly clear
that they believe that the chief factor
in the spoiling of children the key
factor in the wrecking of kids is
parents and that if they the experts
were allowed to indoctrinate your kids
and whatever they wanted then the world
would just be a better place now there's
some people who have been saying this
for years so there's a clip that was
floating around online yesterday from
melissa harris-perry who used to have a
show on msnbc this is from about 2013
but it does sum up what so many
progressives think of of children now
ironically
the demographic group politically
speaking least likely to have children
of their own are progressives the
conservatives have lots and lots of kids
progressives have very very few children
and a dog
but but they think that they should be
able to indoctrinate children because
children are the collective's property
children are how you mold the future so
here is a again this is from years ago
but it is indicative of a mindset that
has now taken deep root inside the
democratic party if it didn't already
have deep root here's melissa
harris-perry circa 2013. we have
never invested as much in public
education as we should have because
we've always had kind of a private
notion of children your kid is yours and
totally your responsibility we haven't
had a very collective notion of these
are our children so part of it is we
have to break through our kind of
private idea that kids belong to their
parents or kids belong to their families
and recognize that kids belong to whole
communities once it's everybody's
responsibility and not just the
households then we start making better
investments lean forward okay so what
the left says
is that they want to help out children
by providing them more resources what
they mean is what they mean is that they
would like to remove your ability to
control how your child is educated
and the values that you teach your kid
you're seeing this in canada right now
with this
lying bill i mean they call it an anti
an anti
conversion therapy bill it's not an
anti-conversion therapy bill it's an
anti-reason anti-religion bill in canada
that essentially suggests that if you
are a parent who does not want to teach
your kid that they can switch sex
or if you're a parent who wants to teach
your kid about traditional sexual
morality and the belief that for example
heterosexual activity is more valuable
community wise and more valuable morally
than homosexual activity if you want to
teach your kid that this makes you a
vicious brutal bigot and and the
government should either find or remove
your child right they should find you or
put you in jail for this sort of thing i
mean that is law now in canada okay that
is what the left would like when it
comes to sexual indoctrination of
children i mean this obviously is
happening in public schools in places
like california new jersey new york this
idea that you have to indoctrinate small
children into the lies of gender theory
so as to twist the brains of small kids
and make them emissaries of your theory
that's the end goal right there is to
make the kids the actual weapons on your
own behalf
it's not good for a kid to be gender
confused but it's good for the gender
confused to gender confused kids because
if you can convince kids that they are
naturally gender confused then you can
make them activists on behalf of a
movement which is why the left so
frequently will use children as
activists on behalf of their movement
and this applies across the board
the left is constantly on an
international level using children as
weapons for their agenda
so for example there's a clip that was
racing around the internet last night is
from quebec
so quebec has basically come to lockdown
central in the west it's like quebec in
australia and this is from quebec tv tv
and it features children ratting out the
unvaccinated and being cheered for it on
on tv
says you are you vaccinated
yes we both have windows
are you
we should call the police
if they don't have a vaccine it can make
a lot of people in danger
so like what the government does right
now we should cut everything from them
little by little until they submit and
get vaccinated
it looks like we've got some future
politician here and people given
big claps big claps from the weird guy
in the small glasses and the giant
mustache and the odd man bun
and the use of children as weapons on
behalf of the state and on behalf of a
status perception of how people should
live is key for the left
now do they actually care about the kids
of course not
children were the demographic group
least affected by covid and yet they
were the demographic group most attacked
by the people at the top levels of
government
there's a clip that was floating around
yesterday from uh from gb news it's
great britain news
and uh it is of a young woman who
it looks like just may have graduated
high school recently talking about the
effect on kids of forcing them to to
wear masks
and and how the covet insanity has
affected kids because these folks don't
care about kids they just want to
control them so that you can't
and the effect on kids of course is
grave
here is this uh this young woman from uh
gb news
it literally ruined our lives
and nobody's nobody spoke about it at
all and the commentators they had union
reps come on and say this is what the
school should have put in place and they
didn't care about what this did for us
and this is the first time i've ever
spoken about on tv because i knew that i
cried about it but i literally watched
and felt like my entire life was falling
apart because of what this government
did to young people and nobody cares not
one person has cared about children in
this pandemic they think unless through
why are we putting masks in them when
people can go to football stadiums and
they can go to theaters and play nadeem
zahari's sitting there at the teaching
awards with no masking yet with
disrespecting kids
this pandemical finish the damage
sister's done for artists forever a
hundred percent she is a hundred percent
right but i don't care about the kids
you're protecting the kids by forcing
them out of school and then by forcing
them to mass go back to school and by
having randy weingarten run things here
in the united states now again
this is a cult
there's a guy named vinay prasad who
writes for tablet among other places
he's a hematologist oncologist and
associate professor of epidemiology and
biostatistics at the university of
california san francisco he has a piece
today titled the cult of masked school
children he says as we enter the third
year of the pandemic every child age
five and up is eligible to receive a
coveted vaccine in the united states
oddly this development has been
accompanied by increased pressure on
kids to wear masks in school some
private schools have gone beyond cloth
masking and now mandated n95 or
equivalent masks for children as young
as four the berkeley unified school
district in california recently began
transitioning students to n95 level
masking this isn't a matter of
protecting children their teachers or
their grandparents it's delusional
dangerous cult-like behavior
he says let's start with cloth masks
which have been the most common type of
facial covering used to cover kids faces
in school in the only cluster randomized
trial conducted during the pandemic
among adults cloth masking failed to
improve the primary outcome of covet
cases that were confirmed with a blood
test
the united states is uniquely aggressive
in masking young kids contrary to
scientific evidence the cdc and the
american academy of pediatrics advise
that kids as young as two should wear
masks europe has always been more
relaxed on this issue and the who
advises against masks for kids under six
and only selectively for kids under 11.
now let's consider n95 equivalent masks
designed to filter a high percentage of
particles to achieve this goal n95 masks
require a snug fit and validation
notably there are no approved n95s for
kids because these masks have not been
subject to validation for young people
all masks sold with this moniker are
merely n95 style masks thought to be
equivalent possibly
what is the goal of masking policy does
it at least help to slow the infection
pre-vaccine it made sense to try to
delay infection until people could be
vaccinated but omicron infects everybody
how about the effects of long covet says
rene prasadi says the best data we have
just between zero and two percent of
kids infected will experience symptoms
beyond any control measures the larger
point is that if infection is inevitable
if it's just a matter of time
considerations of long covet are moot no
matter how we reach the destination
we'll have to help children who develop
long cobit that's true whether we make
them wear masks or face shields or hold
their breath every time they go indoors
and yet we have continued down this path
because again it is not about saving the
children it is about using the children
now you say that you're endangering kids
if you don't force everybody to mask or
if you don't force everybody to
vaccinate or if you don't indoctrinate
kids in gender theory if you don't
indoctrinate them in the insanity of
anti-racist garbage from ibramex kennedy
kids are not things that ought to be
protected according to the left they are
tools to be used for the creation of a
brand new future
we'll get to more of this in a second
because the agenda is 100 clear we'll
get to that in a second first
let's talk about the fact you're
spending too much money on gas because
you are the price of gas has been
inflated for months and months and
months and months at this point well if
you could be saving 25 cents per gallon
every time you fill up why would you not
do that here's the good news you can
head on over to the app store or google
play right now and download the free get
upside app use promo code shapiro get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that is up to 50 cents cash back
do not pay full price of the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
just download the app for free use promo
code shapiro to get up to 50 cents per
gallon cash back on your first tank of
gas some people who drive a lot are
making as much as two to three hundred
bucks a year in cash back there is no
catch the cash back is added directly to
your account you can cash out anytime to
your bank account paypal or an e-gift
card for amazon and other brands just
download the free get upside app use
promo code shapiro to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your first tank
of gas that is code shapiro go check
them out right now
again get that free get upside app use
promo code shapiro to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your first tank
of gas and then 25 cents per gallon on
every tank of gas after that get the get
upside app today alrighty so
the agenda to indoctrinate children
continues a pace
when it comes to masking the idea is
that that allowing children to go to
school unmasked is some form of cruelty
to kids there's a piece by teresa vargas
writing for the washington post today
theresa vargas who is a local columnist
for the washington post she says in
catering to selfish parents young kin is
failing virginia's kids
in catering too selfish but you see the
parents are the selfish ones
the the great and good
expositors of masking for all they're
the ones who care about the kids but
people's own parents don't care about
them
the the
hilarious ridiculous insane and insipid
notion that parents don't care about
their kids random joe cares about your
kids more than you do
it's totally crazy it is contrary to not
only all reality but to all decency
but here's what teresa vargas writes
when children test positive for covet at
my children's virginia elementary school
parents don't normally get much
information we are left to wait and see
whether we will receive an email saying
that student was in close contact with
our child i received several of those
emails this school year each has evoked
me the same quiet worry and frustration
that comes with being thrust again into
the unknown each has brought the same
questions will my children get sick will
my husband or i get sick well our kids
have to stay home from school to
quarantine forcing them to miss lesson
plans and us to figure out how to meet
the demands of full-time jobs and child
care but the one emotion i have never
felt while reading those emails is
annoyance toward the parents of the kids
who tested positive i have felt sympathy
for them and concern for their families
i felt mortified on their behalf knowing
how awful i would feel if i were in
their place how about you calm the f
down lady
omicron ain't killing your kids and if
you're vaccinating you either
but but you are are
so insane that you think that the state
should mandate that everybody your kid's
age
is is supposed to now mask for no
apparent reason you can't provide any
data to support this position
no data at all it's a religious position
but this columnist says the way i have
looked at it is we are in this together
no we are not when you want to control
everybody around you we're all exhausted
but we're doing our best to keep our
school community safe then a message
popped up on a facebook page for the
school community last week it was
written by a staff member it came at the
end of a particularly trying week at the
school one that saw students in seven
classes forced into quarantine because
at least one child in each had tested
positive for covid one of those classes
belonged to my nine-year-old son so
first of all this is because your school
is stupid
you should not be testing asymptomatic
kids period end of story
but says the message many of you were
inconvenienced by the quarantine
protocols enacted in your child's
classroom this past week the message
read several of those class quarantines
would have been avoided if people had
given their actions careful
consideration before doing them
the actions of a few this week have
upset many families and caused a
distress as well as left our staff
stunned and frankly a little hurt at the
disregard for our community's health and
well-being
so
there were three actions that had caused
some disruption two of them children
were sent to school before their
quarantine time was up children were
sent to school whether while their
families awaited coronavirus test
results these were concerning but they
weren't as surprising as the third
result given the paragraph read do not
withhold positive test results all
positive kobe 19 test results are
reported to the virginia department of
health
sending your child to school knowing
they have a positive test is
purposefully putting the community at
risk and will also sprinkle the
quarantining of an entire classroom i
read it again before i accepted what it
was saying parents had lied yeah no yes
they did you know why they lied the
reason that they lied
is because you have set up a completely
unlivable standard
because you have now suggested that the
best thing that a parent can do is never
test their kid
if these parents are smart they're not
going to test their kids
they're just going to wait until they
are asymptomatic from whatever it is
they have and then send them back to
school because they're not testing them
for flu before they send them back to
school
they're just going to wait until the kid
has no symptoms and send them back
which by the way would be the normal way
to treat disease in this country we have
made it completely unlivable for
children we are quarantining kids for 10
20 30 days outside the classroom
depending on how many siblings they have
or their home living situation
but the bottom line for this washington
post columnist is she cares about your
kids more than more than young kid cares
about your kids and that is why she has
to control your kids and youngkin
has to stop catering to selfish parents
it's young kid's fault that all of this
is happening
well maybe it's maybe it's your fault
that this is happening
and this columnist says i'm an arlington
parent i want my children to be able to
attend school again without having to
wear masks i also know it is not yet
safe enough for them to do that
really provide evidence provide evidence
how many kids have died from omicron any
evidence whatsoever please i'm waiting
oh you can't provide because you know
because the evidence is irrelevant
it's not just with regard to masking
kids obviously it's also with regard to
critical race theory
okay so critical race theory is indeed
taught in schools there's a watered-down
version of it that is ibrum x candy
nonsense this is where you teach your
child a five six-year-old child that
they are the inevitable beneficiary of
white privilege in the united states
because all of the institutions of the
united states were rooted in bigotry and
therefore if you are white you enjoy an
inherent privilege under the system that
black people do not enjoy hey this stuff
is being taught to small children
there are kindergarten materials in
particular areas of the country that
mirror the the language of ibrahim x
kendi who is a ridiculous figure
impromex kenny by the way insists that
he is an expert on this stuff despite
not being able to actually define the
term racism
it's a pretty infamous clip of him being
asked to define racism and he says
racism is when racist people do racist
actions
which is like saying define the word red
red is when red things are red oh thanks
abram okay so here is ibrahim x kendi
explaining to trevor noah and company
this is actually uh to his sub host uh
this is abram x kenny explaining to the
daily show
why he is such an expert on race he's
such an expert guys
generally people don't believe in
science
but they really don't believe in racial
science they just think i'm just up
there talking
you know just one day i just decided to
start talking about race and racism that
i wasn't trained to study this that this
isn't my expertise it isn't you're an
idiot he hasn't said a true thing
probably his entire career
trained to study this you mean he got a
sociology degree from nowhere
i mean seriously like this notion that
you are trained to like i want his
scientific credentials for max kennedy i
would love to hear them i would love
nothing better than to hear his
scientific credentials
because his actual education
is he got dual bs degrees in
african-american studies and magazine
production from florida a m
and then he got a phd in
african-american studies from temple
does that sound super but he's a stud
he's he's an expert in racial science uh
first of all last time people used the
term racial science it was real ugly
because it was just racial essentialism
boiled down to nazi physiognomy okay so
racial science is a pretty nasty history
and maybe if you knew anything about
racial history you wouldn't use the term
racial science and then defend it but
if max kenny's an expert and we have to
boil his stuff down for the kiddies now
if you object to this if you think that
this is bad
and if you wish to actually see what
your kids are learning in the classroom
the left has decided this is very bad
because they ought to control your kids
when terry mcauliffe said that
parents should not have control over
their kids the educational establishment
the experts should have control over
their kids
that's what you call a kinsley slip so
michael kinsley the columnist he
suggested that there are two types of
gaps one are gaps where you say
something you don't mean and the other
is where you say exactly what you mean
but you say it out loud
well that that is what terry mcauliffe
did in virginia and it lost in the
governor's race well now according to
nbc news as state legislatures kick into
gear this month republican governors and
lawmakers who have fought to limit
discussions of race in public schools
are lining up to support a new aim
curriculum transparency
oh no parents might know what's being
taught to their kids in schools
lawmakers in at least 12 states have
introduced legislation to require
schools to post lists of all of their
teaching materials online including
books articles and videos
the governors of arizona florida and
iowa who have previously raised concerns
about how teachers discuss racism's
impact on politics and society called
for curriculum transparency laws and
speeches to their legislatures this
month
florida governor desantis said florida
law should provide parents with the
right to review the curriculum used in
their children's schools
some conservative activists say the
effort is a potent strategic move to
expose and root out progressive ideas
from schools it's the next move in a
fight over critical race theory the
academic concept typically taught in
college courses to examine how laws and
institutions perpetuate racism and which
some conservatives have used to describe
ideas in books they believe are too
progressive or political for the
classroom
christopher ruffo who's done
indispensable work over at the
conservative manhattan institute on this
stuff he said the strategy here is to
use a non-threatening liberal value
transparency to force ideological actors
to undergo public scrutiny
but teachers their unions and free
speech advocates say the proposals would
excessively scrutinize daily classwork
and would lead teachers to preemptively
pull potentially contentious materials
to avoid drawing criticism
i love that so you're a free speech
advocate who doesn't want people to know
what their kids are learning in class i
feel like you're not so free speech are
you
but according to the left right teachers
and unions and free speech advocates
they want to be able to teach
your children whatever they want to
teach your children and they don't want
you to know what they're teaching your
kids wouldn't that be suspicious like in
any other context wouldn't that be
suspicious
any time you leave your car your kid in
a room alone with an adult you want to
know that you could walk into that room
at any time everything would be going
fine right
complete transparency is i mean this is
why people leave nanny cams at home
but once you delegate your kid to a
classroom you're supposed to believe
that some teacher
who's a member of a left-wing randy
weingarten teachers union indoctrinated
into leftist belief systems ought to be
trusted with everything about your kid
without any level of transparency at all
according to nbc news
quoting john friedman director of the
free expression in education pen america
a non-profit group promoting free speech
it's important we call this out it's a
shift toward more neutral sounding
language but it's something that is
potentially just as sensorious
pen america has said the laws amount to
an educational gag order it is no less
concerned about the curriculum
transparency proposals which friedman
said are designed to generate more
outrage over lessons on race and gender
in school yes that's correct they are
designed to generate outrage on race and
gender in school because for the first
time in decades parents are actually
looking at the left and realizing what
their game is and their game is to
indoctrinate your kids their game is to
pervert the minds of your children and
make your kids believe stuff that is
overtly untrue bad about themselves and
bad about america
that's the reality and if you by the way
if you're not doing that then what are
you so afraid of
what are you so afraid of why are you so
scared
that we might find out what you're
teaching our children
randy weingarten she said quote good
schools and good school districts have
always had curriculum transparency
including extensive two-way
communication between parents and
educators on what we are teaching and
how to support our kids pretending
otherwise is just the latest attempt by
chris ruffo and others to exploit the
frustration of covid to create a toxic
environment where the biggest losers are
the children nope nope nope nope by the
way if you think that these schools have
always been transparent why are you
objecting to laws that say they should
be transparent
what exactly is the problem
the fact that the left opposes this is
insane
but fully demonstrative of what the
actual agenda is which is we don't want
you noticing what we are doing to your
kids because again the cultural
indoctrination that has taken place in
the united states has done grave damage
to entire generations of human beings
if you think it doesn't matter by the
way
look at the damage done to young women
particularly who have been taught that
the most vital thing a woman can do on
this earth because it is the most vital
thing any human can do on this earth and
only women have the magic superpower is
to have kids and raise them
and yet entire generations have been
indoctrinated by our culture by our
educational system to believe that the
height of womanhood is to sustain
motherhood
and it's had horrifying effects
i'll get to that in just one moment
first
let's talk about the fact that there's a
huge number of car makers and models
that are out there right now what this
means that if your car breaks and you
have to go to the auto parts store to
replace the part there's a really good
shop they actually don't have the part
they're gonna have to order it online
then up charge you well if they're using
a computer to get the part why should
you not use a computer to get the part
you have computers with access to rock
auto at home and in your pocket you
should head on over to rockauto.com at
home in your pocket why would you choose
to spend 30 50 100 more for the exact
same auto parts at a chain store or new
car dealership
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they've got
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet whether it's for your
classic or your daily driver get
everything you need and a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro in there how did
you hear about usbox so they know that
we sent you again rockauto.com go check
them out right now rockauto.com
well we'll get to more on this in just
one moment first if you don't already
know matt walsh is now going viral
because he was on dr phil debating
gender identity activist hilariously
matt asks one activist to find the word
woman and it goes pretty much how you
would think the response has been
enormous matt has been trending on
twitter for more than 24 hours matt has
spoken out against transgender ideology
especially when it comes to kids he
recently became a best-selling
children's author with his new book
johnny the walrus about a boy who
believes he is a walrus and the internet
tells mommy to respect his trans walrus
identity johnny the wall was sold out
originally in 48 hours don't worry more
copies are on the way reserve yours now
at
amazon.com meanwhile luke rosiak one of
our
top journalists he's the daily wire
reporter who broke the national story
about sexual abuse in loudoun county
schools has a brand new book out
exposing public schools it is called
race to the bottom uncovering the secret
forces destroying america's public
school system is a fantastic must read
book you can pre-order it today at
amazon it includes the never before told
story of america's first woke school
system located in seattle tracy castro
gill the director of ethnic studies at
seattle public schools turned math into
math ethnic studies where students have
to explain how math is used to oppress
and marginalize people in communities of
color by spring 2018 that math ethnic
studies program was piloted in six
schools on the next state math exam the
performance of black students at those
schools just tanked so the state named
tracy regional teacher of the year and
they are employing her methods all over
the country to learn more pre-order a
copy of luke rosiak's race to the bottom
uncovering the secret forces destroying
america's public school system today at
amazon you are listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
when we talk about the left and their
control over kids what we mean is that
the left has had intergenerational
effects through their seizing of the
high points in american culture and
education and it's had a massive
terrible impact on the united states
there's a really good piece by a person
named sasha white over a tablet mag
called the woman's place is in the rat
race in today's miserable workforce the
career-centric promises of modern
feminism are hallower and less
fulfilling than ever
one of the most miserable groups of
american workers is women who face a
burnout crisis and report the highest
levels of workplace exhaustion and
dissatisfaction according to this
columnist a 2021 study by mackenzie and
company and leanin.org found that 42 of
women say they feel burned out often or
almost always according to the same
study one in three women says they've
considered downshifting their careers or
leaving the workforce this year
paradoxically women in this country were
promised we would finally be fulfilled
and empowered if we entered the
workforce unlike my mother and
grandmother's generation who were raised
to become mothers and wives my entire
generation was taught that our careers
will give us deep meaning and allow us
to make a difference in the world that
promise rings hollow for several reasons
on a personal level it creates a
mentality in which the loss of one's
career can lead to a devastating
emotional void and on a societal level
it has been manipulated for all sorts of
damaging corporatist ends so why is it
still orthodoxy in most feminist circles
that going to work equals liberation
this exact this is exactly right of
course and again the the simple fact of
the matter is that women's happiness and
satisfaction in life has declined
relative to men since the 1970s
and yet pop feminism has continued to
lean into the corporate system devaluing
any life choice for women that does not
center on economic prosperity
of course this system does not only harm
women
lower and lower and lower middle class
men today are reduced to the third tier
status in today's workplaces too america
is known for its poor treatment of such
workers long hours low wages little time
off no mandated paid parental leave
countrywide only 30 of americans report
feeling engaged at work
yet identity politics obscures that this
state of affairs applies to all workers
and the advocates of careerist feminism
promote the idea that men have a joyous
experience in capitalism that we can
also be privy to if only we could break
the glass ceiling which of course is not
true
you know the the bottom line here is
that
we have taught pathologies to
generations of americans
and then in order to promote the
pathology still further you have to
hijack the next generation of americans
because it turns out that the people who
embrace the let's not have kids let's
embrace sexual hedonism the only thing
that matters is whatever floats your
boat turns out those people don't have a
lot of kids so how do you promote that
agenda to the next generation the answer
is you have to seize other people's kids
the answer is you have to seize the high
points in culture in education and
entertainment and then you have to
indoctrinate an entirely new generation
of human beings in your particular point
of view and you have to stop anybody
from finding out about it if you're
randy weingarten and the teachers unions
okay meanwhile back to joe biden joe
biden has now fomented an absolute mess
in ukraine
according to the washington post
president biden faced a furor on
thursday including a highly unusual
rebuke from ukraine's president and
sharp criticism from republican members
of congress after appearing to downplay
a hypothetical minor incursion by russia
into its neighbor's territory the
administration was hastily thrown into
cleanup mode reassuring allies and foes
the united states would view any
crossing by russian troops into ukraine
as unacceptable aggression this is
because joe biden said in
an open press conference that a minor
incursion would be treated differently
than a full-scale invasion of ukraine
which is an insane statement it is the
just the tip of foreign policy
this prompted
the president of ukraine zielenski it
prompted him to tweet out we want to
remind the great powers there are no
minor incursions in small nations just
as there are no minor casualties and
little grief from the loss of loved ones
i say this as the president of a great
power
and so that is president vladimir
zelinski just slapping biden direct
across the face
members of congress were also critical
of course
senator ben sasse a republican of
nebraska he said the president's press
conference was an absolute train wreck
that will have serious consequences
president biden basically gave putin a
green light to invade ukraine by
yammering about the supposed
insignificance of a minor incursion
he projected weakness not strength which
is of course absolutely one hundred
percent undeniably true
okay so yesterday joe biden had to try
to clean this up and uh clean up on
aisle nine commenced it it didn't go
fantastically well
i've been absolutely clear with
president putin he has no
misunderstanding if any
any assembled russian units move across
ukrainian border that is an invasion
but then it will be met with severe and
coordinated economic response that i've
discussed in detail with our allies as
well as laid out very clearly for
president putin
but there is no doubt let there be no
doubt at all that if putin makes this
choice russia will pay a heavy price
yeah by heavy price he just means more
sanctions that many of our european
allies won't even join us in
right but biden said that himself in the
press conference he said nato is divided
which is exactly what putin wants to
hear if nato is divided there isn't a
unified response
so he said nato's divided over what
happens if they just go and take
the donetsk region for example
and that's exactly what he wasn't
supposed to be saying according to the
washington post quote for weeks top u.s
officials have been emphasizing that
washington is fully united with its
european allies about how to respond to
russia but biden said that was not
entirely the case in all circumstances
suggesting that russian action short of
an invasion could cause a divide among
allies about how to forcefully respond
many officials conceded biden was
probably accurately portraying real
divisions that could emerge within nato
but europe and u.s leaders have been at
pains to emphasize their unity not their
differences biden said in that press
conferences quote there are differences
in nato as to what countries are willing
to do
depending on what happens the degree to
which
we have to go
and of course vladimir putin just sits
in the background chuckling heavily
gensake tried to clean this up as well
she says don't worry don't worry our
allies know what biden was saying yeah
they know that's why they're tweeting
out that they think that he just handed
the place over to vladimir putin
i can assure you that our allies and
partners
know exactly what the president's
position is they knew what it was
yesterday they knew during the press
conference they knew after the press
conference because we have been engaged
closely and working in lockstep with
them for weeks on the rising uh military
uh incursion or threat posed by russia
uh say they know exactly where they
stand they ha they always have and they
certainly do today
uh no they uh then thank you for that
that massively failed cleanup this
president is a failure on every level
and here's the thing again the
underlying agenda is bad it's a very
very bad and nefarious agenda and that's
what americans are responding to they're
not responding to joe biden's lack of
rhetorical flourish they're responding
to the fact that he has been telling the
truth and so is his party the mask is
off maybe the story of american politics
since 2016
is that all the masks are off all the
veils have been removed and we're seeing
for the first time the full ugliness of
what everybody seems to think about
everything
and the american people are looking
direct in the face of the dictatorial
mandates from the biden administration
and their viewpoint on how children
ought to be raised and their viewpoint
on foreign policy and they're saying we
don't like any of this and they are
running screaming the other way
by the way meanwhile joe biden continues
to do the same thing with regard to to
elections
right after spending
two years suggesting that donald trump
was the worst thing ever to happen to
american politics because he was
doubting election results
and he was undermining faith in
america's elections joe biden literally
came out
in a press conference and just said our
future elections will not be legitimate
if i don't get what i want
by the way he's not the only one who
says this vice president kamala harris
was asked specifically about this
yesterday about whether biden thinks the
midterms will be illegitimate and uh it
got awkward because there's no such
thing as vice president harris not being
awkward she's the most awkward human
being who has ever walked the earth
does he think now that these bills
haven't been passed that the 22
midterms won't be legitimate or fair or
free
let's not conflate issues so what we are
looking at and and the topic of so much
debate last night
was that we as america cannot afford to
allow this blatant erosion of our
democracy and in particular the right of
all americans who are eligible to vote
to have access to the ballot unfettered
so i noticed one thing that she didn't
say right there is that the elections
will continue to be legitimate even if
we don't pass this bill
because that's what joe biden said he
literally said the elections will be
illegitimate if we don't pass this bill
he said the the legitimacy of the
election is directly proportional to how
many of the republican bills get passed
which is an insane statement
james clyburn was supposedly one of the
wise old men of the house of
representatives he was a leading factor
in joe biden winning the nomination
james clyburn of south carolina he
openly says unless democrats are running
elections i just don't trust the results
we know the history of alabama we know
the history of georgia florida and texas
south carolina north carolina we know
that history
and so they are now making these changes
and one change is if you give somebody a
drink of water standing in line
it's a felony
that is crazy
so how could it be a legitimate election
if you've got those kinds of things
hanging over you okay so there can't be
a legitimate election unless democrats
are running the election meanwhile gen
saki is trying to clean this up so
yesterday she was asked about she said
no joe biden isn't challenging elections
he isn't yes he is that is the whole
premise of what he's saying
uh honestly jen saki has a terrible job
right being a white house press
secretary is a very rough job is
particularly bad when the president of
the united states is absolutely
incoherent it was hard when trump was
president because if you're the press
secretary and you said something you
didn't know whether trump was
immediately going to say that you were
lying or saying something wrong like
trump would actively come out and shiv
you but if you're gen saki and you have
to defend whatever nonsense spews out of
the oatmeal ridden mouth of the
president of the united states
it's a rough job so here she is trying
to walk back she's trying to clean that
joe biden rhetorical bedpan right here
he was not intending to cast out on the
legitimacy of the 2020 election he was
actually attempting to make the opposite
point which is that in 2020
despite covid despite many attempts to
suppress the vote a record number of
voters democrats and republicans
independents too turned out in the face
of a pandemic and election officials
made sure they could vote and have those
votes counted right according to gensake
the only election that has ever been
good is the one job in one all the other
ones that had different procedures
because covent was not in place
all those other ones are illegitimate so
then jin zaki had no answer because
somebody actually had the temerity to
quote joe biden and and it got awkward
for her
the president said to him i'm not saying
it's going to be legit the increase in
the prospect of being illegitimate is in
direct proportion to us not being able
to get these reforms
passed so yes or no does the president
believe it all remains as it is right
now that the elections this fall will be
legitimate
but yes but what he is what the point he
was making is that as recently as 2020
as we know the former president was
trying to uh work with local officials
to overturn the vote count and not have
ballots counted a giant fail giant veil
everybody now knows that joe biden has
no moral high ground when he says that
you can't challenge election results
you can as long as you're a democrat if
you're a republican you do it this means
you're very bad and evil in undermining
a faith in democracy if you're a
democrat and you do it this is because
you are righteous and you are attempting
to stop
the erosion of democracy and weird how
this works okay so all of this is going
to manifest in very ugly ways for
democrats come 2022 the good news for
democrats according to nancy pelosi is
that the house democrats are the
greatest collection of intellectual
heavyweights in american history you
have to love nancy pelosi just because
there is
so little going on upstairs at this
point i mean
it does say something about the united
states when the top levels of our
political class are all 80 year old
geriatric patients it's it's it's really
it says something here here's nancy
pelosi who also i mean uh her serial
choices are always very interesting uh i
i don't know why she just went and and
apparently got
like a bunch of of 1970s style
beads and and is now wearing them around
her now it's it's a strange sartorial
choice okay here we go
i say to my members
on a regular basis
when we gather in caucus and as you know
sometimes it's
hybrid these days but any time we have
gathered in caucus when we're actually
virtually or hybrid i've said to them
under this roof figuratively or actually
is the greatest collection
of intellect
integrity
and imagination for doing the right
thing for the american people
uh
yeah man
i mean by the way if that's true we are
so screwed as a nation
if that if that collection of
intellectual luminaries is the greatest
collection of intellect and integrity
anywhere
imagination for solving america's
problems
who are you talking about here like eric
swalwell aoc ilhan omar
pramilla jayapal
ayanna presley what uh the luminaries
the brilliance the insane intellectual
those people should probably raise your
kids that's probably the answer probably
if they raise your kids everything will
be fine alrighty we will be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content first you cannot forget to end
your week by tuning in to the andrew
clavin show ruth shows every friday he's
got an exciting evening planned for you
head on over to dailywire.com 7pm
eastern 6 pm central and tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo widowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high event audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin
[Music]